pues de entrada con una reunión de
crisis esta mañana en el ministerio
francés de deportes entre autoridades de
la policía el ministro del interior la
dirección de la uefa la federación
francesa de fútbol y otras autoridades
locales de gobierno el objetivo
declarado de la reunión es sacar
lecciones de lo que la prensa local y
extranjera cataloga como un fiasco una
calamidad entre los puntos del orden del
día la organización del evento muy
criticada especialmente por los
fanáticos británicos los excesos en el
uso de la fuerza por parte de la policía
y la emisión industrial de billetes
falsos entre 30 y 40 mil según la
titular francesa de deportes el gobierno
se toma muy en serio esos incidentes a
la par de esa reunión de urgencia el
jefe de la diplomacia de la policía
parisina pidió al procurador de la
república que abra una investigación
sobre el fraude masivo de tickets
falsificados en estos episodios de
poquísimo civismo no son aislados en
francia- precisamente anoche el partido
entre sant etienne y hoc se terminó con
enfrentamientos violentos y un saldo de
33 heridos entre jugadores entre
jugadores y espectadores el porqué de la
reacción tan alto nivel está
evidentemente en la envergadura de la
champions pero también el gobierno pone
sus bardas en remojo con vistas a los
juegos olímpicos de 2024 y al mundial
del rugby de 2023 se intenta por tanto
neutralizar esa imagen de incapacidad
para organizar grandes eventos
representada tanto en los medios como
por personalidades políticas